i don't know about you guys but i'm
never gonna look at stilettos the same
way
hey everyone thinks story here with
another lovecraft country breakdown and
there is a lot to cover
that huge christina william reveal the
man in the closet
captain lancaster's secret and what is
really hiding in christina's basement
we'll get into all that but first make
sure to like and subscribe as i'll be
breaking down
every episode this season now two
disclaimers before we begin
one i have not read the book so you
won't get any spoilers on that and
two the show deals heavily with racial
inequality
and myself being white understand i
sometimes get things wrong
i really love this show and doing
breakdowns for it so i'm gonna continue
to educate myself on these issues but if
i've missed something
gotten something wrong please leave a
comment or send me a dm on twitter or
instagram
i may not be able to respond to all them
but i do read them and i hope we can all
learn more about these issues going
forward
ruby wakes up in dell's body dell is the
racist woman who kept watch over the
stone tower in artem in episode 2 the
same one who was knocked out by letty
in this episode however she'll take up
the name hillary davenport ruby was last
seen with william and he's given her a
potion which turns her into a white
woman
and it doesn't take long for her to
freak out and cause a scene which
attracts some nearby cops
racist cops who immediately blame a
young black boy instead of the clearly
hysterical white woman
she's taken back to william who readies
her for her transformation
back into ruby metamorphosis or
transformation is this episode's major
theme
ruby transforms into hillary christina
into william
montrose emotionally transforms into
someone who embraces his own sexuality
there's discussion about caterpillars
turning into butterflies and locusts
shedding their skin meanwhile montrose
looks at his bloody hands after he
murdered yahima last episode
atticus punches him in the face knowing
deep down that montrose killed her and
not only that destroyed titus's pages
which they hoped to decipher
we'll find out later that letty luckily
took photos of them before they were
destroyed ruby learns more about this
transformation from william william was
laughed at by the academic community for
trying to apply the process of
metamorphosis to humans
that is until he met a disgraced
professor named hiram epstein
the man who previously owned letty's
home notorious sexual assaulter jeffrey
epstein was
also a professor who was fired from his
job and i can't help but think that this
character was named after him ruby talks
about how it was like being a white
woman how when she was panicking as a
white woman she felt people scared for
her
instead of scared of her william leaves
her another vial of paulie juice potion
which allows her to further experience
life as a white woman free ice cream and
not getting hassled at the park where we
see an ad for a movie called
confidence girl a 1952 film about a
woman who
isn't who she says she is atticus talks
to letty about his violent outburst
against his father
violence he didn't know he had in him
until he fought in korea
we don't know much about what atticus
experienced in korea but if you've seen
the promo for next episode it looks like
it takes place there ruby asks william
of
all the black women why choose her what
makes her special enough for this magic
because we now know that william is
actually christina his response of
feeling magic when he laid eyes on her
probably isn't the truth rather that
christina is just using her
remember that she still wants access to
letty's home in search of hiram's orry
after finding out a mysterious force
field blocks her path she'll also
require a favor in return for use of the
potion
something we'll get to it a bit william
asks why she didn't take the money he
gave
her to which she responds the only
currency she needed was her whiteness
ruby transformed as hillary gets her
dream job at marshalls not only that but
considering her resume she's given the
assistant manager position
if she had gone in as ruby with the same
exact credentials she would have got
nothing
paul hughes the manager remarks on how
the hiring of quote coloreds
was not because of social justice but
because of economics a criticism of
today's corporate culture where
companies don't necessarily do things
because they're right
but because it helps their bottom line
montrose visit sammy at cabrini green
a public housing project in chicago
where sammy lives they hook up
even as montrose still wears his wedding
ring ruby finds out tamara didn't even
graduate from high school so how did she
get this position we'll later find out
the rapist manager has a thing for black
women
there's a great juxtaposition here of
tamra who works her ass off while the
white workers in the back room enjoy an
extended break eating bonbons the racism
is on full display when one of them
recommends tamra bring them to a bar in
the south side of chicago because it
will be just like going on safari
william picks up hillary as the other
girl's swoon a poster for wrigley's
gum in the back william is the poster
boy for whiteness he asks ruby for that
favor to help christina drop this
cryptic rune in captain lancaster's
office
a rune which has the same symbol for
protection atticus discovers but we
can't
100 be sure it means protection since
atticus himself
states he isn't sure if his translation
is analogous to english and why would
christina want lancaster protected we
learned that lancaster shot william in
the back and dumped him in the river
which is likely when christina took
over his persona and why her version of
him doesn't have a gunshot wound on his
back
william was supposed to be the rightful
heir to this lodge but
lancaster took over whatever is going on
here is likely all part of christina's
plan to take over as the head of the
chicago order of the ancient
dawn atticus experiences a nightmare
depicting his ancestor hannah and what
appears to be the book of names
unlike in episode 2 where we see the
same event notice how atticus's clothes
here are different
covered in blood the amount of blood
even changes from
shot to shot but the weirdest thing is
hannah says something to atticus here
that we can't make out
if there are any lip readers here please
leave a comment or dm me i'd love to
know atticus and letty continue to
decipher the pages but are still
encountering problems it's here that
atticus tells mantros killed yahima and
her
instinct is to tell him this whole thing
must be bad if he was willing to kill to
protect them ruby hides the rune in
lancaster's office but holes up in the
closet when she hears him and his men
approaching last episode christina heard
a man who appeared to be gagged in there
but we'll find out he just had his
tongue cut off maybe this rune of
protection isn't for lancaster but for
this man his name is zanone a man who
apparently knows the location of some
loot that lancaster wants if lancaster
wants it maybe christina wants it too
in the credits he's simply known as
reanimated frankenstein
lancaster talks about needing a new
shirt and cologne probably because parts
of his body are decaying he takes off
his shirt and i want to hear your
thoughts on this
is this the torso of a black man we know
hiram epstein did
similar reattachment surgeries from
episode 3 and that lancaster and epstein
were close
there's also a discussion about
protecting the winthrop observatory
which i'm assuming is not the house but
a new location we haven't yet seen
the connection with astronomy is strong
here considering they have some sort of
plan to get christina to bring the oriy
to them he also talks about needing
horatio's pages to
get him in somewhere but to where it's
never really explained
it could be the winthrop home which
we've seen has that force field around
it
and also leads to the underground
tunnels ruby chastises tamara saying
you want to be a credit to your race you
have to be better than mediocre blacks
don't have the luxury of taking long
breaks and eating bon bons like their
white counterparts they have to always
be on their a-game and never slip up
montrose is with a group of drag queens
and we learn he's never even kissed
sammy something he'll later do in his
final act of transformation sammy says
he's going to perform a dance called the
la custa
migratoria or migrating locus those
insects who shed their skin that were
talked about on the television at the
beginning of the episode hillary and the
girls head out to denmark vasey's bar in
the south side of chicago where ruby
will later transform back to her
original form
and watch as her manager tries to rape
tamra something she'll get revenge for
with a finely placed stiletto
ruby asked christina what's in the
basement now that we know christina is
william this basement
likely holds the key to where she's been
getting those vials of blood just like
epstein conducted experiments in his
basement does christina
as well will the bodies of dell and
williams still be down there
held alive like that guy in the closet
for purposes we
still don't fully understand christina
also mentions that she knows what it's
like to be oppressed to being a woman
who has continually been shafted by the
order of the ancient dawn but ruby says
they
aren't really the same she's a black
woman but if there's one thing that can
help them it's the currency of magic
something christina says can give them
unmitigated freedom
atticus and letty have a discussion
about love he's never really known what
love is because he never experienced it
growing up and thus has nothing to
compare it to there was a girl in korea
he may have been in love with but he
says it ended in a strange way he's of
course referring to gia who we haven't
really met yet but apparently next
episode it focuses
on her letty also has her own problems
with love she says her mom and sister
fell in love so easily that it wasn't
special but atticus tells her that what
they have
is and that he's not confused about what
they are anymore
william transforms in front of ruby
revealing himself or
herself as christina whereas ruby got to
experience what it was like to be white
christina got to experience what it was
like to be a man having the ability to
transform into anyone will surely come
in handy in the episodes to come but i
hope we'll learn more about how this
process is achieved and whether the
process has something to do with what's
in that basement
atticus uncovers two new words from the
pages in the subtitles we see that this
first word is
suffer and later when he's on the phone
with gia the second word is
die all in all atticus has uncovered 11
of the letters and whatever else he has
uncovered
not shown to us the viewer jiha had
predicted all we really know here is
that this other woman on the phone
predicted something that involved death
and suffering something atticus didn't
believe her about because she goes on to
ask him
do you believe me now in episode 1 when
he was on the phone with her she said he
never should have
left and now in this episode she's
saying you should have listened to me
atticus's arrival back in america
triggered something that involved this
death and suffering and now atticus
wants to know
what she is is she some sort of oracle a
witch or
something else entirely in the episode 6
promo we hear
jia say this we must have felt what it
is to die that we may appreciate living
is she dead did he die and she save him
after all it appears she's a nurse
there's also the possibility that that
word
die doesn't mean the word at all but
rather their initials just like the a
s and f found on atticus's ring could d
refer to atticus's mother dora and the e
her maiden name which we don't know yet
i'm just throwing out some crazy
theories here i want to hear your
comments and what you thought about this
episode below
thanks for watching everyone please make
sure to like and subscribe and follow me
on twitter and instagram
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much